with so many visitors this weekend many  will rely on ride sharing apps uber  wants to make sure everyone stays safe  the company is strongly recommending  that customers only take rides booked  through the app  riders should also double check that  your ride matches your phone before you  get in  another note uber is still asking riders  and drivers to wear a mask  and if you're celebrating this weekend  with a drink in your hand make sure you  also have  a safe ride home lyft is making sure  that happens with free ride credits this  weekend  the first three thousand new and  existing users can take  five dollars off one ride with the code  smart ride usa  that starts at 5 pm today and lasts  through 5 a.m  on july 5th